- [Instructor] All right,
so I don't know about you,
but I feel like talking about pizza.
It's pizza night over here.
I am smelling pizza as it's in the oven.
It's on my mind.
And I know we're supposed
to be talking about heat
and thermal equilibrium, but
I think we can make this work.
Now, if you're impatient like me,
you probably put a slice
of pizza on your plate
as soon as it comes out of the oven
and you've probably noticed
that the bottom of the plate warms up.
So let's think about what's going on here.
We have the temperature
of the pizza, T pizza,
which is warmer than the
temperature of our plate, T plate.
So, since the temperature
of the pizza is higher
than that of the plate, the
plate starts to warm up.
The pizza's temperature,
on the other hand,
will actually start to lower.
And this will happen
anytime the temperature
of object one isn't the same
as the temperature of object two.
We know temperature is how we express
that something is hot or cold.
What does hot or cold mean?
Temperature is actually the measure
of the average kinetic energy
of the particles in an object.
So let's digest that for a
second and break it down.
So temperature, temperature
is the average kinetic
energy of particles.
And kinetic energy, as we
know, is 1/2 mv squared.
So when the pizza is warm,
its particles are moving
faster than if it was cold.
And when particles and objects are moving,
they're actually vibrating around.
So what's happening in the hotter object
is that the particles are vibrating faster
than when the object is colder,
and that's what it
means to be hot or cold.
This type of kinetic energy,
the motion of particles, is
also known as thermal energy.
Now, you might be wondering,
"If temperature is the measure
of kinetic energy in objects,
and we have the pizza on the plate
with their temperatures changing,
does this mean there's some sort
of energy transfer going on here?"
And you would be spot on.
Heat is the transfer of
energy between objects
at different temperatures.
This is a really important concept,
so let's write that definition out.
Heat is the transfer
of energy between objects
at different temperatures.
As you can see with our pizza and plate,
heat is transferring from the
hot pizza to the cold plate,
from the hot object to the cold object.
Why is that?
Well, let's go ahead and
break down our problem
and really dig into what's happening
with everything in the system.
In real life,
a lot of energy is also
going to be transferred
from the pizza into the air
around it, but for this problem,
we're going to simplify it
to just look at the pizza
and the plate.
So we said that the
higher the temperature,
the more all the particles
that make up the object
are moving and vibrating.
So let's go ahead and draw
that for the pizza particles.
We're gonna use yellow
to represent the pizza,
and I'm going to give the pizza particles
a longer velocity vector
than those of the plate.
And I'm going to assume that the particles
in the pizza and the
plate have the same mass.
That way, we can ignore the
mass part of kinetic energy
and simplify the situation.
Now, we can just focus on the velocities
of all the particles in the system.
When you put the slice
of pizza on the plate,
the particles at the
surface of the objects
will come into contact.
So let's look at what happens
when these faster particles
from the pizza collide
with the slower particles
on the surface of the plate.
When the particles collide,
kinetic energy transfers
between the particles.
Since the hotter object's particles,
in this case, the pizza, have more energy,
they're able to give some of that energy
to the colder object's particles,
which is why he always
transfers from the hotter object
to the colder object.
When the hotter object's
particles transfer some
of their energy to the
colder object's particles,
the hotter object particles
have now lost some energy
and slow down.
So we can show that by using
a smaller velocity vector.
At the same time,
the colder object's
particles have gained energy
and sped up.
So now this particle in the pizza
is at a different velocity
than its neighboring particle
in the pizza.
So when they collide, guess what?
We transfer energy again.
The faster particle will give
some energy to the slower one,
and in the process, it slows down.
And this domino effect carries through
to all the particles in the system,
in the plate and in the pizza,
until all the particles have
the same kinetic energy.
And when the particles in both objects
have the same kinetic energy,
energy will no longer transfer
between the two objects
and the system has reached
a state of stability,
and we call this thermal equilibrium.
You know when you leave your
pizza on the counter too long
and you come back and it's cold?
If you were to actually
measure the temperature
of the pizza and the plate,
they're going to be the same.
And we now know that
heat transfer only occurs
when the temperature is
different between objects.
So when the temperature is the same,
no heat is transferring,
and this is what is defined
as thermal equilibrium.
So thermal equilibrium,
equilibrium occurs when
there is no heat transfer
in the system.
So it turns out pizza
is actually pretty good
for learning about heat transfer
and thermal equilibrium.
And if you don't mind,
that pizza and the other
room is calling my name,
and personally,
I prefer to eat it before it
reaches thermal equilibrium
with my plate.